welcome back to pg chain design today i
would like to show you
how to create this pattern and calculate
it correctly
for a ring band are you ready let's get
started
we are going to start at the front view
and decided how big this ring is going
to be
in my demonstration i like to use 16
millimeter
but suggest you use exactly the ring
size you wanted to do
then i'm going to draw the profile over
here basically
i'm going to have this is about 2
millimeters thick
just over a little bit on 10 millimeter
wide it's pretty wide ring bin
i'm going to making a copy by scaling
down the gumball
and making a copy and moving this up for
like how much how deep you want
on this space here and basically just
using the trim command select both of
them
and i wanted to trim off
the one in the middle so this is going
to be our profile make sure you
join them then i'm going to
moving this from the midpoint to
the quadrant here so now we have this
profile
if you do wanted to them to sit it with
a little bit
dome what you can do is you can creating
another arc snapping here to here and
just make it dome
a little bit like that so you have a
slightly different design
and we are going to explode this one
and did it this one on the side i'm
going to set the stone but
it's always nice to have a fillet edges
there so i'm going to have a small
fillet
so maybe uh 0.25 millimeter
gonna go here to here
and also the same on the right side here
to here and here to here
if you like to have a comfort fit what
you can do
is rebuild this one and then we want to
rebuild into the degree
three with the minimum um point count is
number four and we want to click okay
there
now you can moving those two down so
it will be the comfort fit there and
watch out this corner there we want to
make it nice around
by giving a bigger fitted there so i'm
going to
try 0.5
so it's a nice and round over there okay
so then we are going to go again moving
this one
up if you want the profile to be nice
around here
okay so now that's coming over
um on the perspective i'm going to just
using this curve right here and we are
going to use a sweep one rail
and this is the rail this is the cross
section
now the reason to get this surface is
because this is where we are going to do
the design
and so we are going to use create uv
curve on this one particular
and let's go ahead to take a look on the
top view now to calculate
this correctly i'm going to use the
uh dimension measurement and i'm gonna
measure from here to here
this is 10.51
and to measure from this to this
65.31 okay so
it looks like we can cut it out six
squared there and have a half square
hanging over there
so if we want our pattern is nice and
square and accurate
we actually need to adjust the width
here so let's take a look on the
calculator so i have 65.31
and i want to divide it by seven i do
want to have a seven
pattern so the width i'm having it
should be close to 9.33
all right so we will need to adjust
this into the 9.33 so what i'm going to
do
to have everybody on this curve and i'm
going to
try to 1d scale it down roughly
from this point to this point
and i'm going to scale it down close to
9.33 divided by 2. so
it will be a little bit thinner and
but we will get a better arrangement so
let's give it another try
we are going to do the surface sweep one
and this is the rail this is the cross
section
and we are going to create
uv curve so coming to the top view we
want this one
close to 9.43 so it's not too bad
and we got this for six uh 5.31
all right so it's really close to what
we want that's okay
and we will be a little bit stretching
but that's fine so let's go ahead to
1d scale this guy
and from 0.9 0.43
to 9.43 to 9.33
okay so that way we can cut out the
square perfectly
and that's using the rectangle
and i'm going to hold my shift
and then we are going to use this square
to design
um our design to do our design
and then so let's go ahead to find out
where it's the center by drawing another
line right there so the first element
that we wanted to do is more like a
diamond shape
and i'm gonna use this one to be split
by
this guy then we can have another
line snapping into here so this will be
that triangle half of the shape that we
are looking for
so i'm going to use this one to trim off
here and
using this one to trim off this side
here
all right this is what we are looking
for and i'm going to join it
right and i do not want to have the
edges
touching the edge on the other side so
this one i actually
going to moving this point in a little
bit so
creating some space there and then
simply just have this one
to mirror to the other side
and let's do a test we wanted to have
this one and to do polar array
from this point for four of them
so we'll get the shape like that now if
you do want to have them
uh coming out a little bit more you can
moving this point
out a little bit more if that is the
design that you're looking for
okay so it's looking good there and
we also want to make sure they are
overlapping so
i might want to just
3d scale it up a little bit and we want
to make sure that
i have this coming over here so there's
no hanging
outside of this border there but the
center will be overlapping a little bit
okay and then next things i wanted to do
is i wanted to offset the curve
and this is where we're going to have a
minigram and depends on how
thick the border you want it to have i'm
planning to have
the distance for roughly points
seven millimeter and i want to go inside
there
okay so once i have that one
we can make it into the solid but first
things i wanted to
make sure i'm not making the pattern
higher than what our design is so i
simply want to measure
from here to here and this is about 0.73
so i do not want to over this radius
over here
so we are going to make the high 0.73
on our pattern right so knowing that
we we are going to extrude this one
straight and the number we want to get
is 0.73 so then we will have
a solid there to make it look nicer
i would like to have a filler edges on
all of them
so let's try fillet edges for something
really small like
0.1 millimeter it will looking much
better on the rendering
so then we'll have something like that
okay
then the next thing is we need to make a
milligram so i'm going to
offset this guy to the center so it was
0.7 so i'm going to offset 0.35
so we will have the curve right in the
middle
and i'm going to moving this curve up a
little bit
and also let me turning into the red
colors it's easier for you to see
okay so now we have this red there and
i'm going to make
the beads on it so we're going to
snapping right here
and kind of eyeball like for whatever
size that
fit it for your design so i'm going to
do something like this
okay so now i have that let's go ahead
to
explode the curve that we have so we
only need to deal one side and then we
can kind of
uh mirror to to the rest of the full
side
okay let's give it a try i'm going to
use the command and it is
array a long curve and i'm going to pick
up the object first and then pick up the
curve
and depends on how many do you want it i
kind of
eyeball it maybe we want to have a piece
and that's click ok and see if this is
to
jam now if this is too gem and let's
take a look on the render view
then you may want to use seven piece
instead of
a piece okay all right so i'm gonna stay
with this one you can you can
you know tweak it and you can kind of
try and see
uh what is the best looking for your
design
so simply i'm going to select everybody
here
and just mirror to the other side
and again i'm going to pick up everybody
here and including those two
oh and and these are like those two
and we are going to mirror to the bottom
part
from the center all right so double make
sure that this is looking good and
that's what you want
and if everything looks nice just go
ahead to
bullying union all of them so now we
have this unit there that's going to use
the
polar array and the center is this curve
right here
and i wanted to do four of them so and
that way there will be inter uh
set there and then we can boiling it
later so that is one of the pattern
there
okay the second thing is i'm going to
making a copy
on all of them and using the copy
command we're gonna making this
to here so that way this is uh
the area we have something to to look at
for to do the design you can using the
arc tool and you can snapping somewhere
about
here and somewhere about here and just
moving
up something like this it's up to you
what type of a design that you like to
do
or you can have you know more of a
straight line instead of an arc
it's up to you uh i would like to have
the same
thickness so i'm going to offset this
guy
for 0.7 and coming into the middle
and since we are going to um doing the b
so i'm going to offset again somewhere
in the middle so let's try
0.35 so we have those three lines to
to play with to making the shape i'm
going to have those two
and to mirror to the other side
something like this and with this cross
line there we are just kind of trimming
each other
i'm also going to use this curve to
trim off the extra on the top
and to make them into the closed curve i
am going to
snapping endpoint to the end point here
and end point to the end point here
all right so let's go ahead to select
all the curve
on the border over there and join them
so once we so once we join them we can
creating this thickness
and i simply just going to extrude the
planer curve straight
and i'm going to extrude the same
highest the
rest of the design and we are going to
do the same radius so let's try the
radius
so i'm going to fill the edges and
giving some
radius is similar like what we had
before let's try point one here
and we're gonna click here here and all
the edges on the top we don't have to do
the things on the bottom because it's
going to attach to the original ring
shank
all right so now we have that i'm going
to moving this one
up about the same height that we have
here okay and i'm gonna
making a b here and we are going to use
a sphere
again am i going to snapping close to
where
in the center for about
similar size like this one so now i have
that piece over there we are going to
use the same command
array along the curve and going to
snapping with this piece here
and this curve over here so again we
kind of need to guessing
how many they are so i'm going to
guessing maybe
18 of them and to see if this is looking
good
i also will suggest you to use a render
view to take a look on that
now for 18 of them it seems like this is
tighter and this is looser so i'm gonna
come back again
maybe i need to just adding a little bit
more so i'm gonna
use the um array along curve again
and we're gonna pick up this object and
we're going to pick up this curve
but i do want to add it just a little
bit more like 20 of them
so that way it will look similar with
the rest of the pattern
and we don't need this ball here we
don't need this ball there
okay so we're gonna pick up all the ball
that we have
and then simply just mirror to the other
side for the middle design
i simply just go into uh making a copy
from this point on my age there
and copy to the middle point right there
all right and simply just moving it
up something like this so this will be
the pattern over there
then i can use this curve to trim off
whatever
hanging outside over there right
so now what you see is an open surface
all i need to do is use a command cap
and then we can close it
and i would suggest you boiling unit all
the beads first so they
they stitch up into one shape if you
have all the b
is separate and you try to flow it back
it's it will be disaster
um your computer might crash so then i
want to mirror this guy with the
midpoint over here
then that will be our design so for our
design
uh i don't need to go finish all of them
i actually want to flow
only this pattern back to
my ring so that will reduce the
calculation
on my computer and so i'm going to pick
up
this curve and make it into the solid
with the surface from planar curve
and we are going to pick up the pattern
over here and including this one and
this one
and let's use a flow a long surface
and i'm going to pick up close to this
corner and the target will be
similar corner here so now we are
looking at this one
it flowed nicely over there
and we're gonna pick up all of them
again the front view
and i'm going to use the polar array and
remember that we have the seventh
section on our calculation so i'm just
going to type is seven
and hit enter you can see they will flow
really nice there's no gap and the
pattern gonna go really well there
thank you for watching the part one of
this i will finish the rest of the ring
with the stone setting in the next video
i hope you enjoyed please let me know
how you like it and share
my video so i can reach more people to
learn jury care design with rhino
thank you for watching see you next
[Music]
you